Let's move on to classifications and
the modelling types that are appropriate
for non-numeric target variables.
Earlier, we learn that classifications
or non numeric outcomes are those we
were trying to predict the category
into which a case falls.
Such as whether an electronic device
will fail before a 1,000 hours or not.
Another example is whether a customer
will pay on time, pay late, or
default on a payment.
For example, you might classify the size
of stores into large, medium or
small categories.
When modeling categorical variables,
the number of possible outcomes
is an important factor.
If there are only two possible
categorical outcomes, such as yes or
no, or true or false, then the variable
can be described as binary.
If there are more than two possible
categorical outcomes such as small,
medium, or large, or
pay on time, pay late, or
default on a payment, then the variable
can be described as non binary.
The important takeaway from this
lesson is the ability to determine
if you should use
a classification model and
whether it should be a binary model or
a non binary model.
Ben Burkholder will lead a course
focused on classification models and
will go into detail about
these types of models.